there was always there's always artists
that are active in the city but i always
feel like boston has like as like a
there's never been like a movement on
the mainstream you know what i'm saying
well part of the problem is that like
boston is a small part of massachusetts
which is
but it gets credit for the whole
massachusetts facts so like i mean look
i was like yeah we got boston's face
yeah
that [ __ ] is annoying you know what i
mean but it's like everybody looks at
the whole mass if you look at boston
actually on the map it's like a small
part of massachusetts right so it's like
we got springfield
lawrence lowell
worcester
uh lynn cambridge you know what i mean
all these different places that produce
talent
but i feel like now um
that's shout out to beer too i got a
shot yeah yeah like yeah yeah yeah
now joiner we got joiner yeah from
massachusetts yeah but uh i feel like um
i feel like that like boston just had
like a stigma with it because when you
think of like boston you think of like
white people and racism and [ __ ] like
certain like it's hard to break in to
understand how much culture is in that
city
like the dorchesters or roxburys and
matapians and [ __ ] like that like
but yeah i think it was hard for people
to um understand that good music was
being made out of boston or out of
massachusetts but we're pushing the
massachusetts movement now it's a lot of
talent out there do you think that that
is a uh misconception about the area the
racist [ __ ] because we always hear that
about the sports fans out of
massachusetts the you know we you know
now it's not a it's not a misconception
but it's it's two sides to to everything
right you know what i mean
that's what i would say like like that
exists but that's not the only thing
that of course that exists like i've
never been in the td garden and heard
somebody say some racist [ __ ] right
personally